Các bạn qua một bệnh thằng chiến năm 2018, các quan kể rất đều trà công an tình tới nền cho biết đang đều trà của án dưới,
phía tăng tí thế sẽ ra trên đệ bàn sả bị nghiệp.
Tên nền.
Chứ đó, người dân phát hiện thi thế một phủ lối trong tình trà không quyền về đã phân hình nặng dưới tình.
Nạn nhân đều rất định là chỉ tế tế tế đây, sinh năm 2018, 1 xa hơn nền tình tới nền.
Bằng các biệt pháp nghiệp của công an và sử vật y phạm nguyễn thình nhá, sinh năm 2018,
chú sát hình luôn tình tới nền.
Tại các quan đều trà, nhá hai xong Trung như vợ trong với chiến đe tự tháng 1 năm 2018,
tệ một phòng trò người nguồn an hà, xó hữu thải, hưởng đứa, tình lắm an, cú.
Nghe hành xin thằng tám năm 2018, giữa hai người xe ra một thống, trong nước cái phá, chiến đe dùng giấu tình công,
nhá trưởng trà khiến đạn nhân tử vòng.
Sở đó, nhá bỏ thi tế nạn nhân vào bao bỏ đỏ,
trở bằng xe mái măng đi phía tạng xuống kên ở sát mình nghiệp,
các đưa xe ra vụ việc khoảng 7.9 mấy hịt, buồn ăn thức tục đu trà làm gió,
sử lý thật quy định phát lật.